speaking of like gazelles when that wind
is going to be running like cheetahs
this afternoon i'm afraid so far things
are pretty much on the light side
getting a few breezes down around
southern highlands but overall our winds
have calmed down a lot from the weekend
boy they were up and down a cold front
moved through we went from 90s on
saturday to the 70s yesterday now back
up mostly 50s around the las vegas
valley 41 out at red rock we've got 40
at indian springs look at that below
freezing in caliani 46 in mesquite 54 in
boulder city 48 in searchlight and 58
right now in laughlin with some mid mid
to low 50s in prompt and sandy valley so
all of us are going to get the winds and
that unfortunately is going to create
some really poor air quality as we get
through the day it's going to be tough
to breathe outdoors with all the dust
that's going to be picked up from these
strong winds so just be on alert there's
going to be blowing dust out in the air
anybody with respiratory illnesses
really you should stay indoors as much
as you can so those winds will bring
other hazards of course around not only
blowing dust but trash and debris around
the roads as well as it could pull down
tree limbs shallow rooted trees power
line power lines we could have power
outages and problems at the airport
today it will be breezy much cooler
tomorrow we'll go from near 80 down to
60s for highs tomorrow and wednesday and
then we'll work our way back through the
70s to low 80s and still breezy winds
return on saturday so it'll make it feel
pleasant but just slightly cooler for
easter sunday should still overall be a
fairly nice weekend there is a lot of
rain and snow with this system but it's
mainly going to be soaked up to the
north of us the sierras sierra has
winter weather advisories they are
looking for
maybe some nice snow in the sierra but
it will all be
wrapped up in california and areas north
before it gets to southern nevada all
these areas of red and blue this is all
wind all wind we have to deal with and
anytime we get a high wind warning for
southern nevada that's serious wind 50
to 70 mile per hour winds please anchor
down all your loose items around your
yard your patio they're going to be
strong crosswinds on the roads and
really hard to drive up in the mountains
we're easily looking for 60 plus mile an
hour winds up there in the mountains
today with mid 50s for highs 80 for the
ma for the valley and again those winds
by noon and especially this afternoon
into tonight 50 to 70 miles per hour so
especially in the darkness of night
tonight these strong winds could create
some dangers and definitely do some
damage so be prepared for it we're down
to mid 60s tomorrow 69 on wednesday as
the winds finally back off those are
going to be north winds tomorrow so
they're going to feel extra cool and
those mornings are going to be in the
40s wow that's really strong that's
that's warm jacket weather there the
weekend looks good but breezy on
saturday